OH “THAT TIME OF THE MONTH” …. IT IS
WHAT IT IS.
BUT DID YOU KNOW MOST MAMMALS DON’T EVEN
HAVE PERIODS?!
HUMANS ARE THE EXCEPTION- NOT THE RULE.
IT’S REALLY NOT FAIR.
HEY GUYS I’M SAPNA HERE AT D-NEWS
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT PERIODS TODAY- BUT ALL
OF YOU MEN AND BOYS OUT THERE--- I HOPE YOU’LL
STAY WITH ME!
CUZ LET’S FACE IT- MENSTRUATION IS A MYSTERY...
FOR ALL OF US.
SO, THE POINT OF THE MENSTRUAL CYCLE IS TO
PREP THE UTERUS FOR PREGNANCY.
EVERY MONTH OUR REPRODUCTIVE HORMONES RISE
ON CUE AND STIMULATE THE LINING OF THE UTERUS
TO BUILD UP - it’s called the endometrium
… And it's job is to CREATE A CUSHION OF
BLOOD VESSELS WHERE AN EMBRYO CAN IMPLANT
AND GROW.
BUT IF YOU DON’T GET PREGNANT, YOU DON’T
NEED THAT LINING SO YOUR BODY GETS RID OF
IT- THAT’S WHAT WE CALL MENSTRUATION.
MOST MAMMALS STILL HAVE A CYCLE OF OVULATION,
BUT IF THEY DON'T GET PREGNANT THEIR LINING
IS SIMPLY RE-ABSORBED BY THE BODY.
THAT’S IT.
NO OUTWARD BLEEDING WHATSOEVER
SOME ANIMALS WHICH ARE CLOSELY RELATED TO
US DO HAVE PERIODS LIKE CHIMPANZEES, orangutans,
AND RHESUS MONKEYS.
BUT THE ONLY OTHER MAMMAL RELIABLY REPORTED
TO SHOW MENSTRUATION ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
JOURNAL OF PHYSICAL ANTHROPOLOGY ARE BATS.
YEA- BATS!
HOWEVER, THERE IS SOME EVIDENCE THAT THE ELEPHANT
SHREW MAY ALSO HAVE PERIODS.
THEY'RE KINDA CUTE RIGHT?
BY THE WAY YOU MIGHT REMEMBER YOUR DOG OR
CAT HAVING WHAT YOU THOUGHT WAS A PERIOD BUT,
THEY’RE IN HEAT, AND THAT'S NOT THE SAME.
BUT WE HUMANS HAVE PERIODS EVERY MONTH WE
LOSE IRON AND NUTRIENTS DURING THAT MONTHLY
FLOW…
WHY CAN’T WE JUST RE-ABSORB OUR UTERINE
LINING LIKE MOST OF OUR ANIMAL FRIENDS?
WELL FIRST, IT’S THOUGHT OUR ENDOMETRIUM
IS THICKER THAN MOST SPECIES.
THAT MEANS THERE MAY JUST BE TOO MUCH OF IT
TO RE-ABSORB…
SO IT COMES OUT.
BUT THERE ARE 2 BIGGER QUESTIONS…
IS THERE AN EVOLUTIONARY BENEFIT TO THAT MONTHLY
FLOW?
AND WHY GO THROUGH THIS MADNESS EVERY MONTH
ANYWAY?!
WHY NOT JUST KEEP THE UTERINE LINING ALL THE
TIME WHETHER YOU GET PREGNANT OR NOT?
RESEARCHERS HAVE BEEN TRYING TO EXPLAIN THIS
FOR A LONG TIME.
THEORIES HAVE SAID PERIODS FLUSH TOXINS OUT
OF THE UTERUS AND ONE SUPER-CONTROVERSIAL
THEORY SAID IT CLEANED OUT BACTERIA BROUGHT
IN BY SPERM, BUT THESE AREN'T REALLY SUPPORTED
BY SCIENCE.
IN 1996 AN ANTHROPOLOGIST PUBLISHED A STUDY
IN THE QUARTERLY REVIEW OF BIOLOGY THAT SAID
GETTING RID OF THE UTERINE LINING EVERY MONTH
CONSUMES LESS METABOLIC ENERGY THAN CONSTANTLY
MAINTAINING IT.
BUT OTHERS SAY THAT'S NOT TRUE EITHER -- IT
ACTUALLY TAKES “MORE” ENERGY.
AND, THEN RESEARCH PUBLISHED IN BIO-ESSAYS
IN 2012, CLAIMED IT'S ALL ABOUT GENETICS AND
THERE’S NO REAL BENEFIT TO HAVING PERIODS
AT ALL.
INSTEAD, PERIODS ARE JUST THE INEVITABLE CONSEQUENCE
OF SOMETHING CALLED DECIDUALIZATION.
DECIDUALIZATION BASICALLY MEANS THE UTERINE
LINING IN HUMANS DEVELOPS INTO MORE SPECIALIZED
CELLS WHICH ARE READY TO IMPLANT AN EGG -- AND
FOR SOME REASON, WHEN THERE’S NO PREGNANCY,
THE CELLS ARE AUTOMATICALLY PROGRAMMED TO
SHED.
BUT WHY?
HONESTLY, SCIENTISTS ARE STILL LOOKING INTO
IT.
EVEN THOUGH THIS HAPPENS TO EVERY WOMAN EVERY
MONTH, IT STILL REMAINS A MYSTERY.
MORE RESEARCH
IS DEFINITELY NEEDED.